it is November 5th 2018 so it's time for
another monthly update video in which
I'll talk about what we have coming up
in November and what you might have
missed and might want to check out from
the month of October very busy month I
always begin by highlighting three big
things so with no further ado big thing
number one its UNESCO World Philosophy
day a worldwide celebration
November 15th we have a great event
coming up here in Milwaukee tell you
more about that in the November section
big thing number two as you might know I
gave a workshop at stoic on in London
back at the end of September and I aired
the video for it so if you haven't seen
that and you want to see me in action
talking about partnered relationships
and what stoicism has to do with that
you might want to check out the link
below in the video description and
finally big thing number three I made my
first experiment experiment with YouTube
premieres a little bit earlier this this
weekend and it went off pretty good so
we're gonna do some more YouTube
premieres don't have a date set for that
yet or even know what video we're gonna
premiere but it allows you to interact
with me live as you see the video for
the very first time so those are the
three big things as I mentioned October
was a very very busy month I came back
starting the month from London where I
had been for stoical on and immediately
jumped right back into teaching my my
two courses at Marquette and my class at
Milwaukee Institute of Art and Design
and then I had two other online courses
short courses so they're very intense
startup one with Marist College and one
with Milwaukee Area Technical Institute
so that's a lot of teaching and course
design and interacting with students
that I'm doing I also had a number of
events we had for stoical week we had a
workshop here called stoic philosophy
and the value of money that was
sponsored by
Sophia and the Milwaukee stoic
fellowship I also gave a talk more
recently down in Rockford lessons for
leaders from epictetus is enchiridion
invited by the Center for Ethics and
entrepreneurship to give that talk you
can see the video for that link below in
the video description and I also
continued on with the worlds of
speculative fiction series and we had a
talk on CJ Chara and the Alliance Union
universe really great discussion put a
link to that below as well and we had
our normal events ask me anything
session philosophy chat for my patreon
supporters the half hour Hagel sponsored
Hagel Hangouts and what else
stoic fellowship met this this month and
we also had a really interesting topic
for the philosophy pop-ups one in
YouTube live one in Facebook live when
is it ethical when is it okay to ban or
block people in social media or
platforms so a lot of great discussion
with that it was very busy not only with
my classes but also with my clientele
doing some consulting work in ethics
with several different companies
carrying out my philosophical counseling
work with several clients doing some
academic coaching and quite a lot of
tutorial sessions that's on top of the
classes that I'm teaching and academic
institutions I was also either on
podcast or the podcast finally heared
and I'll put links to those in the video
description as well I was on the
exceeding expectations podcast at Sony
wintered Tom Richie's podcast which he
took a lot of heat for suggesting that
perhaps voting is something that he
could get out of and James and the Giant
podcast talking about stoicism and you
know it's it's rise recently and what
stoicism is all about so that was a lot
of interaction video work I didn't get
as much done as I would have liked I
actually did get a half hour
egle video which was in some respect a
bit of an accomplishment those are
harder videos to put together because
hey it's Hagler right and I got one of
them done this month so that's more than
the two previous months where I didn't
get any done but it's not the six that I
like to shoot for and I really some some
Cicero videos ones I'd recorded
previously I also started editing the
the interview videos that I had recorded
at stoic on so I've released two of them
so far and actually released three to my
patreon supporters but two so far to the
general public and you know we had the
event videos as well I didn't record the
stoic philosophy the value of money
workshop but I did record the one down
in Rockford at the Center for Ethics and
and and entrepreneurship and I did
record the chera and of course the AMA
and the philosophy pop-ups are there for
you as well so that was the month of
October what's coming up in November
well you know personally it's going to
be quite a busy time because as you know
here in America we have that
Thanksgiving weekend which essentially
starts on Wednesday and then continues
through the day of gluttony and then we
have leftovers the rest of the weekend
my kids are gonna be here for that
weekend so I'll be traveling down to
pick them up on the busiest travel day
of the year and it's gonna be great
having them it's always nice for them to
be up here in Milwaukee we're probably
gonna hunker down hang out eat eat
turkey and you know watch some some
movies play some Catan and my son and I
might might do some you know work with
video or podcast we'll see about that
but we're gonna just catch up so that
that's really great events we got a lot
of cool things coming up and some of
them are later this week on Wednesday
the 7th at 6 p.m. here in the Milwaukee
area at the Frank Weinberg library so
up on the north end of things I'll be
doing my quarterly talk on all in this
case albert camus the absurd and the
world that that he lived in we talk
about the philosophers place in history
and man there was a lot of history at
the time of Khemu wasn't there then we
kind of shift gears and we moved to a
different library ap 7:00 p.m. on the
8th which is a Thursday I'll be talking
about Jack Vance's dying earth series at
part of the the worlds of speculative
fiction series by the way we're also
putting together the new list that I'll
be bringing that out soon for who we're
going to talk about next year on the
10th which is a Saturday at 12 p.m.
that's central time of course right we
will be having the dr. Sadler's AMA
that's asked me anything session you can
come in and get your questions in early
because they pile up and I'll try to
address as many as I can then we have
the big event here in Milwaukee I'm
gonna be one of three speakers for that
one on world philosophy day we have at
the Stone Creek Factory cafe we've
booked the entire top floor and we're
going to be doing three workshops on
civility and disagreement my workshop
will be about anger but there's going to
be other ones about what kind of
conversation we're having workplace
issues really great stuff sponsored by
Sophia Milwaukee and then finally the
the other scheduled event is on the 17th
will have at 3:00 p.m. we'll have our
philosophy chat that's for patreon
supporters and will be meeting and
chatting and stuff like that we'll have
plenty of other online events going on
as well the philosophy pop ups patreon
supporters find out about those in
advance everybody else finds out the day
of and we will be doing some YouTube
premieres what exactly I don't know yet
what days I don't know exactly no yet
but trust me there is going to be some
stuff premiered and if you want to do
that it's a lot of fun
you watch
video for the very first time as
everybody else and there's a chat window
on the side you can ask questions make
comments I'll be responding to you and
chat because I may actually I'm not
watching it for the first time because I
had to edit the stuff but which I like
what doing you know I don't actually I
don't enjoy watching myself quite
frankly or listening to myself even
though other people do but I will be
chatting with people and answering
questions same stuff going on this month
lots of consulting lots of philosophical
counseling work academic coaching
tutoring I've got my five classes going
on so I am a busy busy man and what else
you know I'm working on trying to get
more podcast episodes out in the
Sandler's lecture series it did get a
few out on Epictetus but you're actually
releasing another one tomorrow I'm gonna
be going on to the death hangout podcast
recording later this week and it might
be out by the end of the month or it
might be in December what we'll see and
I don't know if anybody else is gonna be
doing podcasting with me I get requests
and you know if I have the time I have
the competence I do them video work so
this month I'm shooting to get back to
my old six half hour Haegele videos and
if I can do that that's amazing if I
can't well that kind of sucks but I'm
gonna do my best at that we'll be
recording the videos for the event so
the camus talk the Jack Vance talk the
civility and disagreement of course you
can see the the replays of the AMA and
the philosophy pop ups I'll be releasing
another interview video this this month
one of the the the interviews that I
recorded at snowicon' and what else book
reviews I'm gonna hopefully get some
book review videos I know I've been
promising them for a long time but I'm
really gonna get to them and maybe even
some Sandler's soapbox videos because I
do have some things I'm kind of riled up
about and
I'll be releasing some more core concept
videos on Cicero's on the ends those on
stoic philosophy and then after then
I've got some Augustine material to
release to you as well and I'm gonna try
to record some stuff from my my classes
on Hannah Arendt Eichmann in Jerusalem
I know YouTube is gonna flag the hell
out of that so that's not monetized rate
because the advertisers hate that sort
of stuff but it's a really great text
and I'm teaching it to two sets of
students this semester so yeah if I can
get that done I'm gonna get that done a
lot of other stuff going on as well but
I think that's probably a good enough
summary of what we've got coming up you
know where to find me on YouTube
Facebook Twitter the usual places and if
you're interested in bringing me in to
talk we've already started filling up
the calendar for 2019 but if you're
interested shoot me an email at Greg at
reason IO and we'll we'll start the
process going if you're looking for
tutorials or philosophical counseling or
some of the other services that I offer
go to my reason io comm website and you
can see all the things that we do a lot
of cool stuff happening down the line
but this is going to be a very very very
busy month as you can tell so hope it's
a great month for you and I'll see you
somewhere at one of these local or
online events
you